bernie devenu une vedette nationale
lorsque vous allez quitter grasset pour
gallimard 82 si vous êtes apparu à la
une des médias ce qui est très rare fin
pour quelqu'un qui travaille dans
l'édition mais qu'est ce que j'avais
fait avant grâce et c'est donc en 64
avant 64 que faisiez-vous commande vient
ton française vernis de boersch vient
pas de recette
ouais tu délires je ne sais pas pourquoi
je suis venu françoise verny alors moi
j'ai pris ils nous sortent de carrière
tout à fait bizarre parce que j'ai fait
des études universitaires écoles
normales supérieures l'agrégation de
philosophie et puis après j'ai voulu
faire une telle ou telle savez tout est
sérieuse et puis cela que me suis aperçu
que j'avais pas d'espoir de ces revues
passe khalid el cheikh une thèse juillet
déjà moi même rassemblé des fiches à me
dire que dix ans après j'aurais pu
j'aurais plus plane fiche que j'aurais
fait le test
alors je me suis dit que j'étais fait
pour autre chose et je pensais au
journalisme
je me rappelle choix du noir le
fondateur du monde hubert beuve méry et
je lui ai dit écoutez j'ai envie de
faire du journalisme jamais connu va ma
vitre compétition pour protéger et il
m'a dit pourquoi voulu faire du
journalisme et je le dis parce que je
m'ennuie à faire une thèse que j'ai
envie de gagner de l'argent à l'époque
lourde
c'était un journal puritains où on
aurait payé à millions de membres mais
on a gardé ou adige amour jeanne on est
en promo pour gagner de l'âge alors je
suis entré dans des journaux dans un
journal catholique chantera la vie
catholique
puis chante radicaux de la mode vous
avez quitté l'écho de la mode donc pour
tous rentrés chez grasset à l'express et
nouveau bravé les nouveaux candidats au
passage alors très compliqué chez
gallimard vous avez quand même eu des
grands succès vous avez fait les noces
barbares jack des succès de cheshire non
mais chez grasset tout le monde le sait
mais chez gallimard comme ça c'est
terminé
j'aimerais qu'on fasse la la liste des
succès et des échecs et succès c'est
d'avoir amené sa gran mallet joris et le
québec
oui et puis d'avoir et d'avoir fait
écrire alexandre jardin marc guillemot
s'est pas mis dans la région vous savez
marie mines et ses compères que j'aime
énormément mais si le jeune femme que
vous prenez ce tête
elle est chanteuse elle joue de
l'accordéon tous à uckange de connu
nausicaa est prêt à cause de son papa
parce que de se dire qu'on peut mais la
pire généraux l'enfant jardin d'enfants
du miel enfants qui fait du bruit
sauf que l'enfant mais c'est est elle en
train de baisser l'attractivité pour
marié j'ai mon père est un génie mais
jai vue pas génie et je dois dur c'était
une grande joie pour moi comme son
premier league et qui d'ailleurs est un
livre il pas tort alors donc ça c'est
les succès les échecs est ce que les
chèques avec gaumont c'est dû à quoi
côté déchets qu'elle gomme hausse est
due à plein de choses je vous le dis
franchement d'abord débit marc à
l'époque dit maintenant que nous l'avons
changé puisque pdg vient de changer de
jour c'est antoine gallimard qui vient
de remplacer son père mais ils vous
voyez claudiennes marque face à daniel
toscan du plantier daniel toscan du
plantier gétaz type merveilleux tu fais
des films proche du jeu qui adore des
opérateurs mettent tous à genech tour
del mar qui avait raconté le savez
fermiers mais ferme il habitera qu à l
avenir
vous voyez jouer une galaxie alors n'est
ce pas y'aura blague gallimard la gomme
et puis on fera une politique de
communication il dit visuels en pro d2
alors le pauvre derrière chaque dame
et puis il se disait lui cet aspect du
plantier ivan pictet démarre on en suit
flammarion maintenant vous êtes depuis
pas deux ans vous avez pas vu passer
sagan été fait là qu'ils ont été achetés
par les presses de la cité c'est à dire
non mais il se passer alors là je le dis
tout à fait franchement chago à deux que
j'aime énormément à d'énormes problèmes
d'argent de fiscalité touchant elle a eu
des propositions mirobolantes mais je
comprends pas bien il y en qui connaît
quelques problèmes à la fois personnel
et financier financiers quand on a vendu
à un million d'exemplaires de masse
barbares comme le prévoit le plan
financier je vais vous dire je ne sais
pas ça va être un goncourt un énorme
concours comme il a eu bien sûr et qu'on
est un peu fou comme des quêtes annexes
ou quand je dis fou c'est que j'aime
bien c'est pas des foins eh bien je vais
vous dire il a dû penser aussi tout
l'argent qui devait d'acheter un énorme
bateau il a fait étape et de bêtise mai
2010 que jamais que je comprends alors
maintenant un an et demi chez flammarion
en effet j'ai fait quoi vous effet rue
racine c'est vous ça j'ai fait vrai
mais je supportais d'amener du sauteur
puis mosci matras ce pas faire c'est de
faire faire puisque mon faux je veux
dire un temps tourne traite de nouristan
qu'il a de faire la même chose de la
pucelle s'adresse à la presse et faire
découvrir de découvrir et de faire
découvrir des talents nouveaux et puis
alors comment ça se passe alors imaginez
quand je vais voir demain matin je vous
dis voilà j'ai envie d'écrire un jour
une proposition alors là je suis pas si
j'ai un rêve j'ai de moi tu peux plus
complètement alors je vais le voir je
m'appelle soir pour savoir si je
travaillais aux gets moi je fais pas
trop de télé voilà et je le dirai à ce
moment-là je jeu pour jouer un rôle
complètement avère moins vous dirait de
terreur du show chez les ménages
mais tout cela mérite que vous avez fait
rive droite du vin et tout ça se guérit
beaucoup plus important c'est le plus
important pour ces missions à l'inversé
quand vous appelez les gens le soir chez
eux pour savoir si une rabat et le même
donneur et ses dérives du web
si l'on dit que vous travaillez gens ce
qui vous arrange
je n'ai vraiment pas je leur demande à
ce que tu abordes je lance de monde aux
faux j'essaie de savoir ce qu'ils sont
en train de faire passer comme le plus
grand votre plus grand succès au goût
trois plus grands succès 10 ans en tant
que faisait justement les gendarmes
genevois tchadien alors est ce là je
crois que je suis plus une patronne de
border line aux risques humains
ouais je n'ai jamais donné du pana j'ai
finalement pas françois xenakis a dit un
jour dans le matin en parlant de vous
que vous aviez un emploi du temps
extrêmement chargé et que quand vous
aviez du temps libre vous saccagé votre
vie en buvant un peu des coudes
réputation
c'est vrai que je suis pas je suis pas
très ménagères de ma vie ou non mais je
suis pas non plus je suis balle en
touche puis sidère d'ailleurs quand ça
ne va pas je n'en suis pas sûr mais
c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup les gens
qui font du choc
et vous ça vous ça vous gêne pendant
qu'on en parle
non non parce que je sais bien qu'un
problème ça vous êtes par exemple on
parle de 5 en ce moment pendant ce nom
alors je voudrais vous dire en suisse
avant est une amie alors et une amie que
j'aime énormément pour lequel jeune tu
manges et françoise sagan à lui à 17 ans
les succès les plus grands qu'on pouvait
revoir
elle se retrouve plus de 50 n'ayant plus
qu'une passion c'est le truc alors ça
moi je vérifie tous les jours
alors je vous dit tout le second n'est
pas une vie raisonnable
peut-être qu'elle ne vienne utilise
qu'elle se droguait que je me comprends
d'autant plus qu'elle est une des
programmes de santé où et pourquoi pas
faire de sago le prototype de trois
cyclos vous jamais eu envie d'avoir une
maison d'édition à vous
mais bizarrement c'est ce que je veux
dire je crois qu'un prévenu dit m je ne
suis pas sûr un bon gestionnaire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu